last time doctor who integrated a trip
to the moon worked out pretty
brilliantly can they do it twice
kill the moon this one i i've really got
mixed feelings about and it's difficult
for me to explain sort of my
reservations or even some of the stuff i
really liked without getting into
spoilers but i'm gonna do the best that
i can so the doctor and clara are on the
moon but something's wrong with it they
bump into a small team of other
astronauts who are there to try and fix
what's wrong with it even though they
don't understand what's causing it and
we have our plot you remember how i
mentioned last time there was a little
bit with a student that i thought was
nifty but they didn't need to revisit
well they decided to revisit that i'm
not going to go into too much detail i
wasn't in love with it but it certainly
worked out better than the last time
that they involved younger characters so
fair play to that now i can't say what
sort of the primary central conceit of
this episode is because it happens far
enough into the episode that i would
consider a spoiler but
to put it simply
it's really kind of ridiculous i mean
even for doctor who it's like wait what
and i'm not sure i really much care for
it however what they use that central
conceit to bring out in the characters
in the doctor and clara particularly is
really stellar stuff i mean ultimately
that's why i'm really torn on this
episode they used a plot and a premise
that i don't really think works but they
use that in order to do stuff with the
characters that works really well so i
guess on balance it comes out evenly
enough i just wish they could have found
a better story to cause these same
character beats that they end up having
i'm really not sure that there's much
more i can say about this or that there
even is much more to say about it and i
will say this about the doctor part of
what's going on in terms of when they
land on the moon is that
he it's basically one of those moments
in time where things could go in a
couple of directions it's been described
different ways over time has been called
fixed points in time fluctuating points
of time things like that have been
described and this is one of those sort
of big moments that's uh you know he
can't just do whatever he wants with it
and what's interesting is what he does
about that is different than anything
that i can ever think of the doctor
doing with a moment like that and that
is where the really interesting
character beats for him and for clara
come from so it's interesting to see it
sort of revisit a general notion not so
much the premise but the this general
notion that we've seen a number of times
before but to have it handled just so
completely differently than it ever has
that's interesting stuff i really do
feel like clara has come into her own as
a character at this point but i also
kind of feel like there isn't a heck of
a lot more to get out of here i really
kind of want capaldi to get paired with
somebody new at this point it's not that
close bad like i said she's gotten
better last few episodes have been much
better but not in a way that i'm like i
want you to stick around for a long time
more in a oh you're gonna end up in a
nice place kind of way or at least
that's the feel i'm getting not sure
what else there is to mention danny pink
gets a nice little moment i really like
where he's kind of landed at this point
um from where we got with him last
episode and just complete side note it
has nothing to do with anything they've
been changing the doctor's shirt i'm not
sure if it's been every episode but it
feels like it i mean the the jacket the
pants that's all stayed the same but the
shirt has changed first it was white it
was black for listen which was quite
memorable this time they put them in a
poke.one let's not ever see that one
again guys please now here's one for you
the doctor and clara they get into these
sort of orange spacesuits that we've
seen the doctor have a number of times
they first showed up in series two so of
the episodes where we've seen these
spacesuits what is your personal
favorite whatever one it is drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned
you